conventional wisdom these days says that
robots will soon put millions of factory
workers out of jobs this may sound like
the fever dream of dr. evil but in fact
there are very pleasant people making
this happen may I introduce Suzanne
Gilbert a budding AI overlord and
founder of Toronto startup kindred AI
[Music]
tell me about these guys so these are
research prototypes so there's some of
the first robots we built at kindred so
we tend to work with small robots it's a
bit like if you imagine a a child
growing up and it breaks a lot of things
now imagine if the child was six feet
tall when it had the brain of a
six-month-old it would be terrible
terribly dangerous how many of these
robots have ever slapped you I have been
hit in the face by a robot so a couple
of Suzanne's seems nice enough
she makes exotic digital arts and she
loves cats to the point where she's
built a robotic fleet of them for the
office this one I believe is called pink
foot
[Music]
it's a quadrupedal bot loosely based on
a cat and that's me although it's not a
very highly faithful representation yet
and then when you were growing up you
had dog things as well yeah that's
correct yeah
so I was really enthralled by
electronics at an Ellie age I guess most
little girls would be looking at trays
of beads and things and I was looking at
trays of white resistors and capacitors
and little components but having the
same kind of reaction to them but don't
be fooled by the hobby electronics and
the cute cat BOTS Suzanne is a keen
businesswoman and kindred has recently
embarked on its first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are learning so they are
continuously running picking up objects
these would run all day all day all
night
powered by state-of-the-art AI these
arms can do something that's very easy
for a human but very hard for a bot pick
up objects of different shapes and put
them down most factories still use
people to do that sort of thing
what's and lots of people today everyone
shopping ecommerce thousands and
thousands of different types of objects
shapes textures weights how do you pick
it up right now it's human so you have
millions of humans in warehouses just
like picking up things and putting it
into another location so we're teaching
our robots how to do that
[Music]
what's the hard part it's figuring out
what's a belt what's a shirt or it's
just how to grasp it exactly it's how to
pick it up right so things will show up
in any shape right and you got to figure
out how to pick it up without dropping
it put it in the location so it takes a
lot of train
part of the training involves of all
things humans robot pilots who manually
control the arms while the AI watches
and learns the finer points of grabbing
for M teach we have a seat so you see a
3d mouse here this lets you navigate the
arm through three-dimensional space
so imagine you're holding the arm in
that left hand and you're just moving it
around move it slowly intently there you
go try get the Oreos I gotta go
Oh shoes though I went too far up want
these Oreos back to the arm yeah
secure the arcade basically I think you
actually get to win so factor
just down the hall
kindred keeps a roomful of pilots doing
the same thing as me only these guys are
actually competent they're remotely
overseeing some arms in a Gap Factory a
thousand miles away in Tennessee how
long have you been a robot pilot just
over a month actually I've only been
here five weeks what was the training
process like almost like playing a video
game like your shirt
god that's a backpack that's a backpack
okay somebody's undies oh there it goes
yeah one shirt at a time
as the arms observe their human guides
they gradually learn how to do better at
picking up t-shirts and shoe boxes
eventually they'll be fully autonomous
and size services will no longer be
required one day this is just gonna
light up and it's gonna be picking
objects pretty much that's that's the
ultimate end goal for at least for these
to have it just constantly worrying and
going and the people will be free the
people will be free to do other more
important so I seemed kind of happy
about the prospect of unemployment but I
was concerned for his future
[Music]
is there something grim about the human
training there and yeah it's not good to
take people's jobs away but this kind of
technology coming into the workforce
should make us start thinking about how
we're going to pay people in the future
because AI is not just going to automate
you know manual labor jobs it's gonna
automate things like doctors and lawyers
and accountants very soon so I think
there's going to be issues there's going
to be a lot of disruption when these
things come online
Suzanne is a realist but she's also an
optimist in her vision of the future
robots won't be mindless competitors to
humanity
they'll be full-fledged citizens like
the rest of us one of the crazy ideas of
Z you talked about was you've got a
robot and it's working in a factory and
then it's got to go maybe it gets paid a
wage and it goes to buy lithium-ion
batteries to keep it going why would
that have to happen I mean for you
having a physical body they will have a
lot of physical needs just like we have
you might have to go to the repair shop
to get like a motor looked up or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone to do that I think they'll
just be contributing to our economy in
the same way we do and if they have
brains like us they'll want to explore
new things I've never seen before
they'll want to learn things they'll
want to perhaps rest so that their mind
has time to consolidate all this new
information should you try to picture it
at my head though so this is the robot
workers they go home and sit on the
couch watch TV you have to work it is I
don't see why not
cat videos it's hard to tell sometimes
if Suzanne is laughing with us
Baretta
either way I plan to clear a nice spot
on the couch for my robot friends boil
up some delicious popcorn and smile
politely thanks for watching and if you
want to see more hello world click on
the link to subscribe